In addition to scatter plots, we
can create several other types
of plots in R. Two examples
are histograms and box plots.
Let's first create a histogram
of CellularSubscribers.
To do this, we'll use
the hist function.
So in your R console type
hist, and then in parentheses
WHO$CellularSubscribers.
Close the parentheses
and hit Enter.
If you go over to
your plotting window
you can see that the values
of CellularSubscribers
are shown on the x-axis and
the frequency of these values
is shown on the y-axis.
A histogram is useful
for understanding
the distribution of a variable.
Here we can see that
the most frequent value
of CellularSubscribers
is around 100.
We can also easily
create a box plot in R.
We'll make a box plot
of LifeExpectancy
sorted by Region.
So back in your R
console type boxplot,
and then in parentheses,
WHO$LifeExpectancy and then
a tilde symbol
followed by WHO$Region.
Close the parentheses
and hit Enter.
Then go over to your
plotting window.
You may need to stretch
it out a little bit
so that you can see all of
the labels on the x-axis.
A box plot is useful
for understanding
the statistical
range of a variable.
This box plot shows how
life expectancy in countries
varies according to the
region the country is in.
The box for each
region shows the range
between the first
and third quartiles
with the middle line
marking the median value.
The dashed lines at the
top and bottom of the box,
often called whiskers,
show the range
from the minimum
to maximum values,
excluding any outliers,
which are plotted as circles.
Outliers are defined
by first computing
the difference between the
first and third quartiles,
or the height of the box.
This number is called
the inter-quartile range.
Any point that is greater
than the third quartile
plus the inter-quartile
range, or any point that
is less than the first quartile
minus the inter-quartile range
is considered an outlier.
This box plot shows us
that Europe has the highest
median life expectancy, the
Americas has the smallest
inter-quartile range, and the
eastern Mediterranean region
has the highest overall range
of life expectancy values.
If you want to give nice
labels to any of your plots,
you can easily do so by
adding a few arguments.
Go back to your R console,
scroll up and then
inside the parentheses type
a comma and then xlab equals
and then empty
quotes-- we're not
going to label the x-axis here
because the regions are already
nicely labeled-- and then
a comma, and then ylab
equals "Life Expectancy".
Close the quotes,
and then a comma,
and then main = "Life Expectancy
of Countries by Region".
Close the quotes and hit Enter.
If you go back and look
at your box plot again
you should now see that
there's a nice y-axis label
and an overall
title to the plot.
Lastly, let's take a look
at some summary tables.
So go back to your
R console and we'll
start by making a table
of the Region variable.
So we'll type table and then
in parentheses WHO$Region.
Close the parentheses
and hit Enter.
This is similar to what we
saw in the summary output
and counts the number
of observations
in each category of Region.
Tables work well for
variables with only a few
possible values, and we'll see
more of this in recitation.
You can see some
nice information
about numerical variables by
using the tapply function.
Let's start by
looking at an example.
So type tapply, and then in
parentheses WHO$Over60 comma,
and then WHO$Region
comma, and then mean.
Close the parentheses
and hit Enter.
This splits the
observations by Region
and then computes the mean
of the variable Over60.
So tapply splits the data by
the second argument you give,
and then applies the
third argument function
to the variable given
as the first argument.
This result tells us that
the average percentage
of the population over 60 in
African countries is about 5%,
while the average percentage
of the population over 60
in European countries
is about 20%.
Let's look at another example.
This time in the
tapply function,
we'll give as the first
argument WHO$LiteracyRate then
as the second argument
we'll give WHO$Region again.
And as our third
argument we'll give min.
Close the parentheses
and hit Enter.
Here we see something
a little strange.
We have the value NA
for all of the regions.
This is because we have some
missing values in our data
for literacy rate.
A common thing to do is to
just remove the missing values
when doing the computation.
We need to pass one additional
argument, so hit the up arrow,
and then inside the
parentheses add a comma
and then na.rm =
TRUE and hit Enter.
This removes all of
the countries that
are missing a value
for LiteracyRate
before doing the computation.
This time we see numerical
values, as we expect.
So we've split the
data by Region again
and computed the minimum
value of LiteracyRate
for all countries with a value
in the LiteracyRate variable.
By using some basic functions
in R, plots, and summary tables
we were able to get a better
understanding of our data.
You'll see more of this in
the recitation and homework
assignment.